bikers and turkeys a motorcycle club
from the historic west side is making
sure no one goes hungry this
thanksgiving
bianca holman reports these men and
women
ride together
and as bikers they always come together
to help their neighbors the 411
motorcycle club from the historic
west side hosted their annual feed or
community event armed with hot plates of
food like turkey
stuffing and streamed beans no one walks
away with an empty belly volunteers also
passed out clothes and toiletries
organizer shantae butler says giving
back is important to the motorcycle
clubs it makes you feel really good
like you know just to put a warm meal in
somebody's stomach and you know just to
let them know like i said like you care
the bikers are the greatest
i have to say they always come out they
always show up and they always bring way
more than you need
so and the whole community i can't even
i can't say vegas strong loud enough
the group fed 700 people in 2019 they
hope to surpass
that number reporting from valley view
in charleston bianca holman
8 news now